الرجل الذي لا ينتهي على ما يبدو ها هو
يواجه بعد ساعتين تقريبا محاكمه غير
مسبوقه لكن السؤال الذي يتردد في ذهن كل
النخبه الحاكمه في الولايات المتحده هل
تجعل المحاكمه من رئيس امريكا السابق
رئيسها المقبل اذا قد يكون ترامب اول رئيس
امريكي حالي او سابق يواجه اتهامات جنائيه
بمثوله امام محكمه في نيويورك الا انه لن
يكون اول رئيس يتم اعتقاله بحسب تقرير
لموقع الاذاعه الامريكيه العامه في الواقع
كان الرئيس الثامن عشر للولايات المتحده
الذي تولى الرئاسه في الفتره من
1869 الى
1877 هو اول رئيس يتم الاعتقاله حدث ذلك
عام
1872 عندما تم ايقافه خلال التحقيق في
عمليه دهس ام وطفلها بعربه تجرها الخيول
في العاصمه الا ان الامر بقي متكتما عليه
لعقود من الزمن قبل ان يفصح عنه الضابط
الذي اعتقله لصحيفه واشنطن ستار في عام
1908 يقول الضابط ويلياموس لقد حذرته مرات
سابقا من تجاوز السرعه لكن اضطررت في
النهايه الى اعتقال لكن الرئيس يليس لم
يكن ضمن المجموعه التي تمت محاكمتهم
ومخالفتهم عللا اذ لم يحضر جلسه المحاكمه
[موسيقى]